COLLINS.
>> OUR COMPANY OWNS HARPER
GET MOVING.
TONIGHT IN NASHVILLE, THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT SPY GATE
AS WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DO YOU LIKE THE FACT THAT
THEY HAD PEOPLE INFILTRATING OUR
CAMPAIGN.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
PEOPLE INFILTRATING OUR
CAMPAIGN.
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS BIG
BEAUTIFUL ARENA RIGHT NOW THAT’S
INFILTRATING OUR CAMPAIGN.
WOULD YOU PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND.
THAT WOULD TAKE COURAGE.
NOW LOOK AT WHAT’S GOING ON.
NEVER IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY HAS SOMETHING TAKEN
PLACE LIKE TOOK PLACE DURING
THIS ELECTION.
>> JOINING US NOW, EXCLUSIVELY,
THREE PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY AND HARSHLY
IMPACTED BY ROBERT MUELLER AND
HIS PIT BULL ANDREW WEISMAN’S
WITCH HUNT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL.
LET ME ASK YOU ALL A SIMPLE
QUESTION.
I TURN TO YOU, CARTER, FIRST.
WERE YOU SPIED UPON?
DID A SPY APPROACH YOU?
>> I’M NOT SURE, SEAN.
THERE ARE TWO PARTS OF THE FAKE
DNR REPORT JANUARY 2017.
FIRST IS HACKING.
WE KNOW I HAVE BEEN HACKED,
EVENTUALLY.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
KNOW.
THIS IS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE.
THIS IS THE GUY THEY USED THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
PHONY DOSSIER TO SPY.
ROB ROSENSTEIN SIGNED OFF AND BY
THEN THEY KNEW IT WAS LIES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE OTHER THING IS FAKE NEWS
PROPAGANDA WHICH LED TO THE PHIA
WARRANT.
>> WHY DIDN’T THEY SAY TO THE
FBI SPRING OF 2015.
WHY DIDN’T THEY SAY -- YOU NEVER
MET TRUMP, RIGHT?
>> NEVER.
>> WHY DIDN’T YOU SAY THIS GUY
WENT TO RUSSIA, WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT HIM?
>> THERE’S NOTHING TO IT.
>> WHY WERE YOU IN RUSSIA?
>> GAVE A SPEECH.
>> NO.
>> IT’S BEEN REPORTED YOU ARE A
DOUBLE CIA OPERATIVE.
>>> YOU COOPERATED WITH YOUR
COUNTRY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> FOR THE BETTERMENT OF YOUR
COUNTRY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU WERE DEBRIEFED?
YOU DON’T LIKE THE QUESTIONS, DO
YOU?
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
>> YOU LOVE AMERICA?
>> YES.
>> YOU WERE TRYING TO HELP YOUR
COUNTRY MEETING WITH INTEL CIA
PEOPLE.
THEY ASKED FOR MY HELP AND I
DIDN’T SAY NO.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> SAM CLOVE IS, LET’S START
WITH YOU.
YOU WERE APPROACHED -- I KNEW
WHO THE GUY WAS TWO WEEKS BEFORE
MENTIONING HIS NAME.
YOU WERE APPROACHED BY THIS GUY.
WHAT DID HE SAY TO YOU?
>> WHAT HE WANTED, HE USED
CARTER PAGE AS THE PERSON TO
GAIN ACCESS TO A MEETING WITH
ME.
WE MET 2016 IN THE WASHINGTON
D.C. AREA.
HE USED ME TO CREATE AN
INTRODUCTION TO GEORGE POP DO
THAT LIS.
PAPADOPULOS.
I DIDN’T KNOW THIS INDIVIDUAL
SUBSEQUENTLY MET WITH GEORGE.
I HAD NO IDEA ABOUT THAT.
IT WAS SO INNOCUOUS I DIDN’T
REPORT IT UP THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND.
I DIDN’T THINK ANYTHING OF IT.
>> HE SAID I’M A POLICY GUY,
THREE CAMPAIGNS, I WANT TRUMP TO
WIN.
MEANWHILE, HE WANTS INFORMATION
FROM YOU.
FAIR STATEMENT?
>> HE DIDN’T TRY TO GET
INFORMATION FROM ME.
I THINK WHAT THE MEETING WAS
ABOUT, THEY USED ME AS A WAY TO
GET AN INTRODUCTION TO GEORGE.
HE WANTED TO GO TO GEORGE
PAPADOPULOS.
HE USED ME TO GET TO GEORGE.
THAT WAS THE CHAIN OF EVENTS
THERE.
I THINK WHAT THE GOAL WAS WAS TO
CREATE A LINKAGE BETWEEN AN
AFFILIATE OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
BACK TO THE E-MAILS, AND IN
ORDER TO CREATE MORE PROBABLE
CAUSE, TO CREATE MORE PROBABLE
CAUSE FOR FIZA WARRANTS AND TO
WE HAVE ALL THREE APPROACHED BY
THE SPY IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
MIKE, TELL US YOUR SIDE.
YOU WERE APPROACHED BY THE SPY.
IMAGINE IF THIS WAS HILLARY’S
CAMPAIGN.
IMAGINE CIVIL LIBERTARIANS,
IMAGINE THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA
IN THIS COUNTRY, HOW DIFFERENT
THE NARRATIVE WOULD BE.
>> I BELIEVE I HAD AT LEAST TWO
AND PERHAPS MORE BY INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE TRYING TO OFFER
INFORMATION TO THE CAMPAIGN THAT
WOULD HAVE JAMMED US UP IN SOME
WAY.
SAM AND CARTER WERE APPROACHED
TO A SPY.
I DON’T CARE WHAT THEY CALL THE
SPY, HUMAN INTELLIGENCE,
WHATEVER.
HERE IN BUFFALO, YOU CAN CALL IT
ELONGATED CYLINDRICAL SPAGHETTI.
WE CALL IT A SPY HERE.
THEY HAD TO DO A LOT MORE.
>> WHO LIES TO A JUDGE?
>> WE WOULD BE LIKE THAT GUY IN
GOOD FELLAS, WATCHING OUT FOR
HELICOPTERS AND TOMATO SAUCE.
I’M CONVINCED --
>> WHAT CONGRESSMAN OR SENATOR,
I DON’T THINK THERE IS ONE, IF
THEY GOT INFORMATION ON YOUR
OPPONENT, WOULDN’T TAKE THE
MEETING?
NAME ONE.
ANYONE THAT SAYS OTHERWISE IS A
LIAR.
I DON’T BELIEVE THEM FOR A
SECOND.
HERE’S WHAT I WANT OUR AUDIENCE
TO UNDERSTAND.
COLUMN ABOUT HOW ROBERT MUELLER
RUINED MY LIFE.
LISTEN, SEAN, IT’S LIKE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IT’S NOT ABOUT ME.
IT’S ABOUT US.
I THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE DAMAGE
THIS DID TO OUR VOLUNTEERS ON
THE COMMITTEE.
LOOK WHAT IT DID TO SAM.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I HAVE
HAD A CHANCE TO TALK WITH HIM IN
A YEAR AND A HALF.
ALL OF THE SUPPORT HE GAVE
TALKING THROUGH THE LIES PUT OUT
BY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, AND FAKE
MEDIA OUTLET.
>> IT’S LIKE A SIEVE FROM THE
CITY COUNCIL’S OFFICE.
SAM, HOW WAS YOUR LIFE IMPACTED
BY ALL OF THIS?
YOU ARE LAUGHING, BUT I DON’T
THINK IT’S FUNNY.
>> I’M CALM.
I HAVE GREAT FAITH.
IT’S GOOD TO COMMUNICATE WITH
CARTER AGAIN.
ONE OF THE REASONS, I LEFT
GOVERNMENT THREE WEEKS AGO.
I WAS IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
I LEFT THE ADMINISTRATION.
ONE OF THE REASONS, THERE WERE
MANY, BUT ONE OF THE REASONS I
LEFT, I WAS NOT ABLE TO DEFEND
MYSELF.
I SAID THAT’S ENOUGH.
I’M TAKING THE MUZZLE OFF.
I’M GOING TO TELL EVERYONE WHAT
THIS HAS BEEN ABOUT.
WHAT MICHAEL AND CARTER TALKED
ABOUT, I AGREE WITH MICHAEL.
THEY HAVE COME AT US IN MULTIPLE
DIRECTIONS AND AVENUES AND FROM
MULTIPLE AGENCIES.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
TO KNOW, THIS IS THE WORST
POSSIBLE ABUSE OF POWER AT
TAXPAYER EXPENSE.
I HAVE TAKEN THE OATH OF OFFICE
THREE TIMES.
I HAVE SWORN MY OATH TO THE
CONSTITUTION THREE TIMES.
WE HAVE ANY NUMBER OF PEOPLE,
MANY HIGH RANKING PEOPLE IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT TOOK
THE SAME OATH, AND THEY WOULDN’T
KNOW IT IF IT BIT THEM ON THE
BUTT.
>> THAT’S A POWERFUL STATEMENT.
MICHAEL, YOU NEARLY LOST YOUR
HOUSE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE STEPPED UP
TO HELP YOU.
REAL QUICK.
>> THEY REALLY DID.
IF IT WEREN’T FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE GIVING MONEY TO PAY FOR
MY LEGAL FEES AND MORE, I’M
STARTING TO PAY OTHER PEOPLE’S
LEGAL FEES, THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
TODAY, I SPENT PHOTOCOPYING
PAPERS ABOUT A JEALOUS HUSBAND,
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THE
ELECTION, JUST FOR ROBERT
MUELLER.
THAT’S HOW RIDICULOUS THIS IS.
>> ACCIDENT MORE ON LAWYERS.
>> LAST WORD.
>> THE SENATE SHOULD DEMAND SAM
IS BROUGHT ON AS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF AGRICULTURE.